[Music]
uh Jack and Allie forever
am i right the chemistry was instant the
minute that she was kind of to let me
come and talk to her about this
potential project but now lady gaga is
shutting down all those rumors that she
and her co-star Bradley Cooper were a
thing Bradley is a brilliant filmmaker
to be the lead actress in his first film
it's an absolute privilege he told me
all you have to do is trust me and I did
in an interview with Oprah Winfrey for
Elle magazine the 33 year old singer
opens up about those dating rumors
surrounding her and Bradley after this
performance at the Oscars
[Music]
yeah you remember that performance they
were all up in each other's personal
space
singing shallow and giving each other
some serious bedroom eyes
[Applause]
[Music]
Gaga tells Quino quote for me as a
performer and as an actress of course we
wanted people to believe that we were in
love okay mission accomplished
but get this Gaga calls suppress very
silly for thinking it was real the fact
that we forged a friendship by creating
art together is kind of the most idyllic
way to to to use that chemistry mama
monster added quote we wanted people to
feel that love at the Oscars Gaga says
she and Bradley worked for days on the
set and that it was all very planned out
and orchestrated performance so yeah
they were acting again in truth when we
talked about it we went well I guess we
did a good job
yeah give them the freakin Oscar because
I was fully shook I'm talking John for
full-body goosebumps he's so talented
and he's such a visionary and he's so
brilliant I mean it really it could just
make me cry like I just believe in him
so much and I believed in him before he
ever came to my home I just thought he
was the one of the most brilliant actors
in the world and then when I met him in
person he was one of the kindest people
I've ever met and we were so comfortable
together and you know this this whole
thing that's happening it's a it's it's
beautiful now you might remember that at
the time the two really had people
talking because Gaga had recently split
from her fiance Christian Kirino
and Bradley was just months away from
announcing his break up with Irina Shayk
but despite all that too hot to handle
chemistry on stage
Oprah says that Bradley told her he was
only able to give Gaga those loving eyes
because the romance rumors weren't true
quote he said his Catholic guilt would
have never let him be able to look you
in the eye at that piano you know a
hundred people can be in a room and 99
don't believe in you and just one person
believes in you and it can change
everything alright alright so our dreams
of Bradley and Gaga
being a real-life Jack and Ally without
all the tragedy of course main
becoming true but they are still pretty
cute besties and I'm happy settling for
that we talk all the time of course
et will be here to bring you all the
latest Bradley and Gaga news so make
sure to keep it locked right here until
next time I'm Hallie Stevens bye for now
[Music]